What's up Marvel fans?
I am here with JB Smoove.
What is up?
How are you?
My wife Shah, Shah XO.
Who is this lovely lady?
Shah XO right here Yes indeed.
You look so beautiful tonight.
I love this pink on
you like cotton candy.
Wow, thank-- thank you!
And we love cotton candy!
Gosh I like it here.
This is great.
You guys are great.
Can you stay here all night?
This is awesome.
We can, we can
for a little while.
Well you both look incredible.
I feel like that
has to be stated.
You guys look wonderful.
I have a question.
What has Mr. Dell been up
to since we last saw him?
Mr Dell has been--
his superpower is the
power of knowledge.
Unlike these amazing
powers that Spider-Man has,
his power lies in books.
His power lies in motivating
these young people to become
better versions of themselves.
And that's his power.
It's an amazing gift!
Amazing gift of power!
And I'm a man of science.
Mr. Dell is truly
a man of science,
as you saw in the
previous movie.
He just wants to make sure these
young people get the exposure
to science that they need!
Science makes the
world go round.
I like that.
That's a superpower we all have.
Yeah.
What are you most excited
for with the film tonight?
I want to see my husband!
Like, of course I love Spidey.
But this is my man!
I can't wait to see
him do his thing in it,
so that's my truth.
No, I love that!
That's so exciting!
So everyone knows Peter
Parker is Spider-Man.
How does Mr. Dell react to that?
How does he feel about it?
Mr. Dell was pretty upset.
When you have a student's
back for all this time
and you find out
something like this,
that they didn't tell
you, and you felt
you had a close relationship
with this student,
and this is what happens.
You know, they pull
the wool over your eyes
and you find out
something like this.
Mr. Dell was pretty upset.
He was not too happy about that.
A little heartbreaking.
He thought they
were like this,
but turns out they
were like this.
It'll be like that sometimes.
Well, it was so lovely
talking with you guys.
Have an amazing rest of your
night and enjoy the movie!
It's going to be fabulous!
We cannot wait!
[MUSIC PLAYING]